les expériences à réaliser une drôle de
pâte qui dégouline parfois ça coule
parfois ça ne coule pas le matériel de
la fleur de maïs maïzena de l'eau
du colorant alimentaire, un verre, un bol
premièrement rempli un verre de fleurs
de maïs puis verse la poudre dans un bol
Mets dix gouttes de colorant dans la
moitié d'un verre d'eau
deuxièmement verse l'eau colorée dans le bol mélangez
doucement avec une fourchette
ça doit résister quand tu remues si
c'est trop liquide rajoute un peu de
poudre
tu as une pâte tout bizarre du slime
la pâte à l'air liquide elle coule de la
fourchette enfonce doucement ton doigt
dans le bol il traverse maintenant enfonce ton doigt très vite il reste bloqué
prend un bout de pâte fait une
boule puis ouvre la main ça dégouline
Beurk ! tu as fabriqué du slime
Comment ça marche ? la fleur de maïs c'est
des tout petits grains ces grains ne
fondent pas dans l'eau ils sont juste
mélange et quand tu enfonces ton doigt
doucement les grains se pousse si tu vas
trop vite
ils n'ont pas le temps de bouger il se
coincent. En fait les grains peuvent
dégouliner mais tout doucement. Essaye
d'enfoncer ton doigt dans des grains de sable ça fait pareil
merci d'avoir suivi
cette vidéo on retrouve d'autres
expériences sur le site de l'espace des
sciences rubrique junior